تتحدث مع صديقك حول شيء ما وما انتم سكه
هاتفك حتى تشاهد اعلانا لنفس الشيء امر
شائع اليس كذلك التفسير البديهي ان
هواتفنا تستمع الينا لكن المفاجاه ان ذلك
لا يحدث طبقا لكثير من خبراء التقنيه
وكبرى شركات التي تنكر ذلك في الواقع لا
تحتاج التطبيقات الى التنصت لمحادثاتك
لاظهار اعلان لمنتج او خدمات يكفيها ان
تتعرف على سجل البحث الخاص بك والمواقع
المفضله عادتك في التسوق الالكتروني
المشتريات السابقه ثم مشاركه هذه
المعلومات مع المعلنين طيب ماذا نفعل حتى
نطمئن ببساطه يمكن ان نختار الا يصل
التطبيق لبعض خصوصياتنا الا وقت استخدامه
فقط في النهايه نحن من نسمح للتطبيقات
بتشغيل الكاميرا او الميكروفون او الوصول
الى معرض الصور والفيديوهات ومواقعنا يفضل
ايضا ان تاخذ الجوله في هاتفك وتحذف
التطبيقات التي لا تحتاجها ولم تستخدمها
لاشهر
وفي حال لازلت لا تشعر بالراحه يمكنك
ببساطه تعطيل المساعد الصوتي سيري او جوجل
التي تستمع لمحادثتك ترقبا للاستجابه وقت
ما يتطلب منها ذلك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات